Speaker 1: We're continuing to follow as we
continue to get closer and closer to the 2022
midterms, different races, primaries, elections
and campaigns that are going on.
One that's really important is the Georgia
gubernatorial race.
Georgia played such an outsized role in the
2020 election due to the focus on it by those
falsely claiming that Donald Trump actually
won the state rather than Joe Biden.
Joe Biden really won in Georgia in 2020.
One of the people running in Georgia for governor
is a woman named Candace Taylor.
That's and GISS is the spelling of Candace,
a very disturbed woman.
Not only does she seem completely clueless
about every single issue she was asked about
during a recent debate, we looked at some
clips earlier this week.
She has a new ad that is like nothing I have
ever seen.
I'm going to play it for you.
It's sort of like Christian dominion est fear
porn.
It's like a two, roughly two minute video.
And the entire concept is that there is a
satanic regime which her governorship would
demolish.
You might notice that that has definitely
like a Q and on sort of sound to it.
You really have to hear and see it.
And I understand that it seems like satire.
I get that it feels like a skit, but it's
real.
Take a look at take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Some are even say they had to get
our permission.
To at least tell us ahead of time.
Even if we didn't believe them.
Over 4 billion people have been injected with
seven to just nine months to create.
Speaker 1: So anti-vaxx.
Speaker 2: Ask yourself why.
Back.
In biblical times, human sacrifice was a form
of demonic worship.
Speaker 1: Worst demons.
This video also contains a depiction of an
alleged Jewish ritual sacrifice.
It's a really anti-Semitic thing from the
Nuremberg Chronicle.
Speaker 2: Still doing it in present day by
killing our unborn.
Speaker 1: Antiabortion.
Speaker 2: Same demons.
Speaker 1: Anti-Vaxx, anti-Semitic, anti-abortion
farces.
Speaker 2: The same scene.
It's just a different time.
Speaker 3: This is a long shot and.
Unidentified: Of itself running for governor
against an incumbent.
Why are you doing this?
Speaker 2: Good question.
We don't call things out that we don't acknowledge
them and we don't take authority and take
dominion over what God has given us.
Speaker 1: So dominion is an important word
for these folks.
I mean, they are quite literally Christian
dominion rests in the use of that word is
very specific.
Speaker 2: Then we are no better than the
evil ones that put it up.
We've watched as people have destroyed our
history and monuments and in their place they
have erected statues to their own gods.
The New World Order is here.
Speaker 1: New World Order.
So.
So, look, I mean, think of it.
Look at what's adding up here.
Anti-Vaxx.
Anti-Semitic.
Anti-abortion.
Ghosts.
Demons.
And Satan.
New World Order.
Conspiracy.
Speaker 2: And they told us it was coming.
It's a battle far greater than what we see
in the natural.
It is a war between good and evil.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So that this is it feels like it must be a
skit.
Who could possibly be this delusional in this
paranoid and this disconnected from reality?
Reality.
But it's real.
And if you look at the comments online, there
are people who are genuinely unsure whether
it's real because it's so absurd.
This is someone who sounds like they need
professional help.
If you met someone like this and if it wasn't
a campaign ad, but it was a dinner party and
they told you that they believed the things
that this woman says she believes in.
The ad you would say delusional paranoia.
And unfortunately, there's a bunch of them
running in some races.
They're all like this, at least in the Republican
primary, I should say.
All of the choices are like this, horrifyingly
dangerous.
And we are barreling towards a disastrous
2022 midterm where folks like this could win.
Think about that.